Social learning is a learning theory
that puts very explicit emphasis on
the interaction and collaboration among
people during the learning process.
It was derived from Albert Bandura's
work and just like Jean Piaget
suggested, that authentic experiences
are really important for developing
a real understanding, or constructing
a real understanding of some topic,
Bandura suggested that part of that
authenticity is the authentic social
interactions that
happen during learning.
That we learn together and
we develop our concepts of
different material together.
And it's really important to preserve
that in any learning environment, but
this presents a real problem for
online learning.
Because in online learning,
we lose the most accessible device for
facilitating this kind
of social learning.
And that's the physical classroom.
In a physical classroom we can
actually talk to one another,
interact face to face.
Online we don't have that as much.
So how do we develop that for
the online environment?
So this really brings up two questions.
First of all, how does the loss
of that physical environment,
that physical classroom
impact online learning?
How does it change what students learn?
Does it actually hurt us?
And secondly, how do we develop devices,
develop technologies,
that can actually resolve this issue.
Assuming that it does damage the
learning if we don't have access to this
kind of interpersonal collaboration and
interaction?
Can we develop devices that
actually help alleviate that,
that facilitate that interaction online?
Now I'm obviously very biased,
because I work on this program and
I love this program.
I think that with technology,
not only can we develop ways
to overcome this difficulty.
Honestly, I think in
the online environment,
we can develop technologies
that make it even better.
One of my favorite experiences in
this program has been that, I can
logon to the class forum and interact
with ten students in five minutes.
And then come back an hour later and
do it again.
And that's a level of interaction,
a level of collaboration that I could
never have in a physical classroom.
And so, I really think that with
the right effort and the right designs,
we can create and leverage
social learning in a way online,
that actually goes beyond
what we can do in person.